what is happening there reject nation we are
about to go watch the bullet train trailer
but before we go into any of that thank you to
the amazing sponsor i mean it amazing sponsor
displayed for sponsoring this video if you don't
know diskplate makes gorgeous art prints on
durable metal sheets that are so easy to display
and swap out there are over 1 million designs
in their store from original art to some of our
favorite ips like marvel dc and star wars and you
won't need any power tools thanks to diskplate's
magnet based mounting system which takes all of
about 20 seconds to install weeds got a couple
of the star collection got the spider-man and
batman up on the wall up here in the studio to
uphold the brand and i just pulled this one out
of the packaging i'm gonna be hanging this up
somewhere in the living room i'm gonna let the
misses decide where this one goes so if you're as
jealous of that displayed as i am hit our special
link in the description box to save yourself
23 on your first one or two displays or 27
if you buy three or more support stem supports
the channel they'll even plant a tree for each
one you buy so really you're supporting
planet earth now let's watch some youtube
hi there's a gun this is the quiet car god he's
your small inside voice in his son there's a gun
wow brian tyrande
love it talk to me i am ready you are getting
the new and improved me because if you put
peace out in the world you get peace back
absolutely getting what you do for a living
take the gun every job i do somebody dies i'm
not that guy anymore some conflicts require a gun
lots of guns
hey this is nice
okay what am i snatching and or
grabbing a briefcase you said you
wanted simple for your first job back
it doesn't get simpler sure bad bunny
you stab me
there's nothing simple about this job something
else going on here yeah i'm not the only one on
this train looking for this case where's
the briefcase i was saying taylor johnson
it was just here we are right
on settlement i love the castle
that's a [ __ ] deal
oh no thank you you know what do
you have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you tomorrow
i'm sure you want to talk
this out no particularly okay
there we go if you're gonna do a movie called
bullet train there better be a moment where
they're hanging off of the bullet trains the
only thing you need there's just one epic ass
ensemble right there david leech my man this is
why that brad pitt cameo happened in deadpool 2.
to produce this one specific movie i'll do your
movie if you let me show up in a day yeah dude
man we got brad pitt in here we got aaron
taylor johnson we got hiroyuki sonata from
mortal kombat and freaking the wolverine which was
like the first movie that always comes to mind for
me when i think of a bullet train the wolverine
movie yeah yeah you're pretty good sonata you got
freaking brian tyree henry joey king is in here
he's a great actress fantastic actress also being
british here you got logan lerman who looks like
they show him die in the trailer which was kind
of a surprise zozzy beats michael shannon the guy
from warrior andrew copeland andrew kojie andrews
is in there is she i didn't see her did you
see her i think she's over the phone yeah she's
playing the role that lady gaga was originally
going to play oh yeah this is john's most
anticipated movie that's right man everything
about this film i don't know everything that
happens in this movie yeah marie beetle let's
do this based on a book all right and actually
something i was surprised to learn um someone who
i was uh part of the bridal party for recently
andrea abby knows i was looking at imdb this
morning like oh crap she's in this movie so so you
got that hey track you got all the secrets hey i'm
gonna go ask her like tell me every detail that
happened in this film it was like working with
brad pitt yeah so it's like five assassins aboard
a train all looking for this one briefcase while
they have to battle it out on a bullet train yeah
i don't know the novel whatsoever other than that
little brief description what we're getting here
is awesome because this feels different for david
leech like it seems like he's been going down like
action comedy route way more it's like to debut
alongside chad stachowski for the john wick movies
with the direction he's got with like fast and
furious like hobbs and shaw deadpool too and now
to see him pulling off this movie right here it's
like such a pure action comedy and i actually love
to see it day and age with so much marvel and dc
it's nice to get an original ip you know to see
this exactly my boy exactly five men riding like a
bullet train yeah this looks fun man it's got like
a quentin tarantino guy richie type of vibe more
guy ritchie i'd say than quentin tarantino yeah
this excites me because it does look like kind of
a nice blend of david leech isms like you have a
certain comedic edge but it looks maybe a little
more soaked in that neon vibe that like an atomic
blonde might bring the perfect next step i
feel like certain point he's gonna have to
start stretching his legs and really surprising us
with a slow moving sea drama yeah with no action
whatsoever the action is the dialogue and it's in
black and white square aspect ratio just the exact
farthest from this as you can get now this looks
like a really fun time but also like the action
and just like the the punch behind the camera is
gonna be so involved like i feel like we've talked
about the david lynch and shed stahelski movies
which are all lynched by the way david lynch
is bullet train it's it's 6 30. actually david
leech they're close to david leach but yeah like
because you know chad stahls has pretty much
just done john wick and david leach has gone
off and yeah done more and more you know sort of
heightened action comedies this looks kind of like
the right mid level for him to get like you know
some of that john wick bone crunch back without
sacrificing the fun that we know he's capable of
and the style and the you know visual flare he's
able to bring behind the camera well i like seeing
like a lot of the wacky characters here like aaron
taylor johnson just having such a fun time i still
feel like he's such an underrated actor i think
he's truly a gem so to see him here i'm excited
to see him bounce off of brad pitt it's pretty
much just gonna be a movie where you're watching
the legendary oscar-winning brad pitt have fun
bouncing off of a bunch of amazingly talented
actors as well so i think that's part of the joy
to behold here i want to get a better taste of the
action because that's the part where david leach
can be kind of interesting to me about sometimes
it seems like he's really getting down the comedy
he did atomic blonde right that was what he did
the action of tom guan was awesome then with
deadpool 2 while the action was really cool and
same thing with you know hobbs and shaw weirdly
i still felt like it was missing some of like oh
that david leech flair where i feel like we're
getting a lot more of it here though yeah you
know the tangibility of the fights that especially
something like atomic blonde brought that you
didn't get in a deadpool or in a hobson shot yeah
yeah i like seeing brad pitch as having just aft
after winning an oscar doing a role where he just
seems like he's having so much fun where he's
yeah the coolest stunt man ever and apparently in
this he really wanted to do as many of the stunts
and fights as he possibly could so you know again
jon's most anticipated movie right he's doing
the keon reeves thing but i like the approach of
like he seems like he's really got a good
grip on the tone because it seems like this
is such a specific tone like a dude who who is
a professional but he also just wants to be a
normal guy yeah yeah i like that style as opposed
to just normal guy who's caught up in a situation
way over his head yeah it's charming he's got
a certain optimism i'll say the thumbnails and
images they released made this seem like it was
going to be some like hairy ass serious movie yeah
like oh this is like less really funny yeah it
just looks brad pitt looking dramatic yeah all
right guys what did you think about this trailer
please leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell thank you to display for helping
us sponsor this video we will catch you all soon
you